양자 얽힘은 입자들이 아무리 멀리 떨어져 있어도 서로 연결될 수 있게 해줘요. 정말 직관에 반하는 개념이죠.
아인슈타인조차 이게 사실이라고 생각하지 않았어요. 오늘 "교실 속의 Qiskit" 에피소드에서는 Bell의
정리가 아인슈타인의 생각이
틀렸다는 걸 어떻게 증명했는지 얘기해 볼게요. "교실 속의 Qiskit"에 오신 걸 환영해요. 이 시리즈에서는 Qiskit을 활용해서 양자 컴퓨팅 관련 강의에서 흔히 다루는 핵심 개념들을
탐구해 볼 거예요. 각 영상에는 상호작용형 모듈도 함께 제공되는데,
아래 설명에 링크가 있으니 꼭 확인해 보세요. "양자 동전" 영상에서는 양자 중첩을 측정하는 게
어떤 면에서는 동전을 던지는 것처럼 본질적으로 확률적인 과정이라는 걸 얘기했어요. 그런데 우리가 어떻게 이걸 알 수 있을까요?
양자 입자가 측정 결과를 사전에 비밀리에 갖고 있는데, 우리가 그 정보를 이론에 담아내지 못하는 것은 아닐까요?
양자역학 초창기에 이 질문은 논쟁의 중심에 있었어요.
크게 두 진영이 있었는데, 한쪽에는 양자역학이 불완전하다고 믿었던 아인슈타인이 있었어요.
다시 말해, 계를 완전히 기술하는 데 필요한 변수들이 빠져 있다고 본 거예요. 아인슈타인은
이 이른바 숨은 변수들을 찾아내면 양자역학의 역설적이고 확률적인
측면들이 해소될 거라고 생각했어요. 반대편 진영에는 Max Born이 있었는데, Born은
양자역학이 제시하는 확률적 기술이 자연이 규정하는 전부라고 주장했어요. 다시 말해,
우리가 입자를 측정하기 전에 그 상태를 모른다는 게 아니라, 측정 전에는 입자가 확정된 상태를 갖지 않는다는 거예요.
수십 년 동안 많은 사람들이 이 논쟁은 결코 해결되지 않을 철학적 문제라고 생각했어요.
어쨌든 계에 대해 뭔가를 알려면 측정을 해야 하니까요. 그렇다면 측정 이전의 상태에 대해 어떻게 알 수 있을까요?
그러다 1964년에 물리학자
John Bell이 방법을 찾아냈어요. 그의 논문에서 Bell은 한 쌍의 얽힌 입자들의 측정 간 통계적 상관관계를 분석했어요.
만약 측정 전에 입자들의 상태가 어떤 알려지지 않은 숨은 변수들에 의해 결정된다면,
그 상관관계에는 상한이 있다는 걸 Bell이 밝혀냈어요. 반면 양자역학이 예측하는
상관관계를 계산해 보니 그 한계를 위반한다는 걸 발견했어요. 이렇게 해서 그는
아인슈타인과 Born의 관점을 명확하게 구분할 방법을 찾아낸 거예요. 이제 남은 건 실제 입자로 직접 실험을 통해
이 상관관계를 검증하는 것뿐이었어요. 숨은 변수 통계를 따르는지, 아니면 그 규칙을 위반하는지 확인하기 위해서요.
이 검증은 수년에 걸쳐 점점 더 정밀하고 정교하게 수행되었어요.
현대 물리학에서 가장 중요한 실험들 중 하나예요. 너무나 획기적이었기 때문에
2022년에 세 명의 물리학자에게 노벨상이 수여됐죠. 요즘은 누구나
Bell 검증을 수행할 수 있어요. Qiskit에 대한 약간의 지식과 IBM 양자 컴퓨터에 대한 접근 권한만 있으면 돼요. 이 영상에서는
Bell 부등식의 논리를 설명하고, IBM 양자 컴퓨터에서 Bell의 예측을 어떻게 검증하는지 보여드릴게요.
Bell 부등식은 여러 가지 측정과 논리 층위를 포함하고 있어서 따라가기가
조금 어려울 수도 있어요. 하지만 단계별로 살펴볼 거고, 결국엔 그만한 가치가 있을 거예요. 우리는 곧
얽힘이 실재하고 아인슈타인이 틀렸다는 걸 보여줄 거예요. 이걸 직접 해봤다고 말할 수 있는 사람은 많지 않죠. 자, 이제
Bell이 제안한 내용을 살펴볼게요. 얽힌 입자 쌍을 여러 개 만들 수 있는 방법이 있다고 가정해 봐요.
이 쌍들은 입자 하나가 둘로 붕괴하는 붕괴 과정을 통해 만들어질 수 있어요. Stern-Gerlach 실험 영상을 보셨다면
입자가 스핀이라고 불리는 고유 각운동량을 가질 수 있다는 걸 아실 거예요.
스핀 0인 입자 하나가 스핀 1/2인 두 입자로
붕괴한다고 해봐요. 그러면 각각의 스핀 1/2 입자는 스핀 +1/2 또는 스핀 -1/2 중
하나, 즉 스핀 업 또는 스핀 다운으로 측정될 수 있어요. 하지만 이들은 스핀 0인 입자에서 붕괴했기 때문에, 둘을 합치면 여전히
총 스핀이 0이어야 해요. 따라서 하나가 업으로 측정되면 나머지는 반드시
다운이고, 그 반대도 마찬가지예요. 이 입자들은 이런 모습의 얽힌 쌍을 이뤄요.
하나가 업으로 측정되면 나머지는 다운이고, 그 반대도 마찬가지예요. 입자 1은 왼쪽,
즉 -X 방향으로 날아가서 Lucas라고 부를 연구자가 그 스핀을
측정해요. 입자 2는 반대로 오른쪽으로 날아가고,
또 다른 연구자 Rihanna가 그 스핀을 측정할 수 있어요. Lucas와 Rihanna는 독립적으로
측정 장치를 회전시켜서, 각자의 입자 운동 방향에 수직인 어느 방향으로든 스핀을 측정하도록 선택할 수 있어요.
얽힌 상태를 여러 개 Lucas와 Rihanna에게 보내면,
그들은 측정 통계를 수집할 수 있어요. 만약 항상 같은 축을 따라 측정한다면, 이 통계는 별로 흥미롭지 않을 거예요.
한 명이 스핀 업을 측정할 때마다 다른 명은 스핀 다운을 측정하고, 한 명이 스핀 앞을 측정할 때마다
다른 명은 스핀 뒤를 측정하는 식이죠. 하지만 두 연구자가 서로 다른 축을 따라 측정하면 더 흥미로운 결과가 나올 수도 있어요.
Lucas와 Rihanna에게 측정할 축을 세 가지씩 줘 볼게요.
이 축들을 a, b, c라고 부르고, 각각 서로
120° 간격으로 떨어져 있어요. 이 실험에서 우리가 던질 질문은, Lucas와 Rihanna가 세 축 중 어느 것이든 자유롭게 선택해서 측정할 때
두 사람이 같은 부호를 얻는 건 얼마나 자주일까요? 분명히 Lucas와 Rihanna가 같은 축, 예를 들어 축 a를 선택하면
같은 부호를 얻을 수 없어요. 입자들의 스핀 합이 0이어야 하니까요. 하지만 서로 다른 축을 선택하면
그들의 측정은 어떤 상관관계를 가질까요? 아인슈타인에 따르면, 입자 상태에 대한 이 양자역학적
기술은 불완전해요. 그는 가능한 모든 스핀 측정의 결과를 사전에 결정하는 숨은 변수가 존재해야 한다고 생각했어요.
그렇지 않으면 얽힌 입자들이 서로의 측정 결과를 즉각적으로 통신해야 하는데, 한 쪽이
저 멀리서 업으로 측정되는 순간 나머지도 순식간에 다운이라는 걸 알아야 하니까요.
저 쪽에서 업이었다면, 여기 있는 건 즉각적으로 다운이라는 걸 알아야 해요.
이 숨은 변수들은 실험 결과에 대한 어떤 복잡한 지침 세트라도 될 수 있지만, 핵심은
각 입자의 스핀 상태가 따로따로 결정되어 있다는 거예요. 그러면 통신이 필요 없죠.
실험적으로 보면, 그건 Lucas의 측정이 Rihanna의 입자에 아무런 영향을 미치지 않는다는 걸 의미하고, 그 반대도 마찬가지예요.
이렇게 되면 두 측정 간의 상관관계에 어느 정도 한계가 생겨요. 하지만 Born에 따르면, 이 상태
ψ가 측정 전에 입자 쌍에 대해 말할 수 있는 전부예요. 따라서 한 입자의 측정은
다른 입자의 측정 결과에 영향을 미쳐요. 이는 측정 간 상관관계에 다른 영향을 줄 수 있어요. 각 이론이 이 상관관계에 어떤 영향을 미치는지 살펴볼게요.
숨은 변수 이론에서는 측정 전에 이미
Lucas가 세 축 각각을 따라 무엇을 측정할지 결정하는 비밀 지침 세트가 있어요. 예를 들어 이 지침들은
Lucas가 축 a를 따라 측정하면 양수,
b를 따라 측정하면 양수, c를 따라 측정하면 음수일 수 있어요.
이를 +a, +b, -c로 쓸 수 있어요. 그렇다면 Rihanna의 입자는
어느 한 방향의 총 스핀이 0이 되도록 -a, -b, +c 변수를 가져야 해요.
그래야 임의의 단일 방향을 따른 총 스핀이 0이 되거든요.
이 스핀 0 조건을 만족하는 가능한 지침 세트는 8가지예요. 따라서 새로운 입자 쌍이
Lucas와 Rihanna에게 전달될 때마다 이 8가지 지침 세트 중 하나를 담고 있을 수 있어요. 자, 이제
입자들이 표에 주어진 비밀 지침 세트 중 하나를 담고 있다고 가정하고,
Lucas와 Rihanna가 각각 독립적으로 세 축 중 어느 것을 측정할지 선택한다면,
두 사람이 같은 부호를 측정할 확률은 얼마일까요? 1번 또는 8번 행의 지침이라면,
측정 축에 관계없이 두 입자는 항상 반대 부호를 가지므로 이 확률은 분명히 0이에요.
그런데 2번 행의 지침은 어떨까요? Rihanna가 c축을 따라 측정하고 Lucas가 a 또는 b 중 하나를 측정하거나,
Lucas가 c축을 따라 측정하고 Rihanna가 a 또는 b 중 하나를 측정하면 같은 부호를 얻을 수 있어요.
이렇게 하면 가능한 측정 조합 9가지 중 4가지에서 Lucas와 Rihanna가 같은 부호를 얻게 돼요.
각 지침 세트에 대해 이를 계산하면, 3번에서 7번 행도 마찬가지로 4/9의 확률을 보여요.
이는, 아인슈타인이 옳고 이런 숨은 변수들이 측정 결과를 사전에 결정한다면, Lucas와 Rihanna는
절대로 4/9보다 큰 확률로 같은 부호를 측정할 수 없다는 걸 의미해요.
이게 바로 Bell 부등식이에요. P ≤ 4/9. 그리고 곧 보여드리겠지만, 얽힌 입자들은 이를 위반해요.
양자역학이 무엇을 예측하는지 알아보기 위해, Lucas가 a를 따라 측정한다고 해볼게요. 두 가지 결과가 가능해요. Lucas가 스핀 업을 측정하면
Rihanna는 a를 따라 스핀 다운을 측정하고, 또는 Lucas가 스핀 다운을 측정하면 Rihanna는 a를 따라 스핀 업을 측정해요. 하지만
우리가 원하는 건 Rihanna가 a뿐만 아니라 자신이 선택하는 어느 축을 따라서도 Lucas와 같은 부호를 측정할 확률이에요.
그녀가 b 또는 c를 따라 측정하면 조금 복잡해져요. 알고 보면,
Rihanna가 한 방향으로 측정할 결과를 100% 확신한다면, 약간의 기하학으로 다른 축을 따라
업 또는 다운을 측정할 확률을 계산할 수 있어요.
어떤 상태가 항상 한 축을 따라 스핀 업을 측정한다면, 다른 축을 따라 스핀 업을 측정할 확률은
두 축 사이 각도의 절반에 대한 코사인의 제곱과 같아요. 조금 복잡하지만
무슨 뜻인지 보여드릴게요. Lucas가 a를 따라 스핀 업을 측정하면, Rihanna가 a를 측정할 경우 스핀 다운을 측정할 것임을 100% 확신할 수 있어요.
이를 벡터로 표현할 수 있어요.
이 경우 이 벡터와 다른 두 측정 축 B와 C 사이의 각도는 모두
60°예요. 따라서 그 절반은 30°이고,
30°의 코사인은 여기에 표시되어 있어요.
30°의 코사인 제곱은
3/4예요. 이제 Lucas가 a를 따라 스핀 다운을 측정한다면 어떨까요?
Rihanna는 a를 따라 스핀 업을 측정할 거라는 걸 알아요. 여기에 또 다른 벡터를 그릴 수 있어요.
이 벡터는 다른 두 축 B와 C 각각으로부터 120° 떨어져 있어요.
같은 기하학적 방법을 쓸 수 있지만, 이번에는
60°의 코사인을 구해야 해요. 따라서
60°의 코사인 제곱은 1/4이에요. Lucas가 a를 따라 스핀 업과 스핀 다운을 측정할 확률이 같으므로,
Rihanna에 대한 이 두 확률을 평균 내야 해요. 최종적으로
Rihanna가 Lucas와 같은 부호를 측정할 확률은 1/2이 나와요. 즉 P
= 1/2이에요. 1/2은 4/9보다 크므로 Bell 부등식이 위반돼요.
이는 양자역학의 규칙이 성립하는 한 숨은 변수는 불가능하다는 걸 의미해요. 이제 Qiskit과
IBM 양자 컴퓨터를 사용해서 실제 양자 측정으로 Bell 부등식을 검증할 수 있어요. Lucas와 Rihanna 입자의 스핀 업과
스핀 다운 상태를 양자 컴퓨터의 qubit의 0과 1 상태로 대응시킬 수 있어요.
두 qubit을 사용할 거예요. 하나는 Lucas의 입자를, 하나는 Rihanna의 입자를 나타내고, 이 quantum circuit으로 얽어놓을 거예요.
두 qubit은 두 와이어 q0과 q1으로 표현되고, 이
X, Hadamard, CNOT gate의 조합이 Lucas와 Rihanna의 입자 사이에 있었던 것과 같은 얽힌 상태를 만들어요. 이제
각 qubit을 측정해야 해요. Lucas의 측정은 a축, 즉 Z축을 따라 설정할게요. 그러면 Rihanna의
측정은 a, b, c 중 하나가 될 수 있으니, 이 세 경우 각각에 대해 세 개의 별도 circuit이 필요해요. 하지만 이
영상에서는 하나만 할 거예요. 전체 내용은 설명에 링크된 모듈에서 확인하세요. Rihanna가 B를 따라 측정한다면,
우리의 circuit은 이렇게 생겨요. 여기서 Ry는 Rihanna의 측정 축을 변경하기 위한 120도 회전이에요.
Qiskit의 Primitive Sampler를 사용해서 이 실험을 여러 번 실행하고
측정 결과에서 통계를 수집할 수 있어요. 0 0과 1 1 두 열은 Lucas와
Rihanna가 같은 부호를 측정한 경우를 나타내는데, 그게 바로 우리가 원하는 것이에요. 따라서 두 입자가 같은 부호를 가질
확률은 거의 1/2에 가까워요. 이는 Bell 부등식을 위반하는 거예요. 이는
두 입자가 얽혀 있다는 걸 의미해요. 어떻게든 각각이 상대방의 측정 결과를 즉각적으로 아는 것처럼 보여요.
이 얽힘을 정확히 어떻게 해석해야 하는지에 대해서는 아직 의견이 엇갈리고 있어요.
얽힌 상태를 측정할 때 무슨 일이 일어나는지에 대한 이런 질문들은 더 철학적인 문제이지만,
이론 자체는 이 시점에서 부인하기 어려워요. 얽힘은 분명히 실재하고, 이건 Bell 덕분에 알게 된 거예요. 그의
부등식과 그것을 검증하기 위한 실험을 수행한 많은 물리학자들 덕분이에요. 그 물리학자들 중 한 명이 되어
양자 컴퓨터로 직접 Bell 검증을 수행하고 싶다면, 설명에 링크된 Bell 부등식 모듈로 가보세요.
시청해 주셔서 감사해요. 다음 시간에 만나요.